Bienvenue
J'ai envie de vous dire bienvenue sur FastGoodCuisine puisqu'on est
dans une cuisine.Je fais ma petite pub.Franchement, ce serait ouf qu'il trouve. J'espère qu'il va trouver. Après bon, je l'ai un peu
embrouillé déjà.Je vous raconterai en fin de vidéo. Par contre, la recette ça va être délicieux. On va cuisiner
sur ma chaîne.Voilà.
L'animation FastGoodCuisine est terminé.
Salut à vous peuple des internets. Aujourd'hui, on se retrouve pour la première fois en 500 vidéos de ma chaîne dans ma cuisine.
Ceci est ma cuisine. Ici, je me nourris, je fais à manger et j'ai un chef avec moi. J'ai pas n'importe quel chef,
j'ai Fastgoodcuisine. Ouais mon gars. Et le défi aujourd'hui, ça va être de trouver sa recette.
-Bonjour, bonjour, tu m'as proposé un truc génial, c'est-à-dire, t'avais une idée de recette à faire ensemble et tu t'es dit ok mais que si
je devine la recette.C'est la première fois de ma vie ça.    -Parce que je regarde tes vidéos, je me suis dit : "Bon,
qu'est-ce que je pourrais faire avec
toi, du coup?" et là je me suis dit : "oh! mais il faut qu'il devine une recette!" S'il arrive à faire ça, c'est exceptionnel!
J'ai deviné pas mal de choses sur cette chaîne :
des films, des musiques, des machins, des jeux vidéos.-Des mots de passe -Et tout. Par contre, une recette,
la cuisine, c'est pas un domaine que je maîtrise de ouf.
-T'as pas les ingrédients. Moi, je pensais vraiment qu'on allait faire cette vidéo, que j'allais te présenter un peu les ingrédients machin etc.
Enfin, une liste d'ingrédients
et que toi, ça
puisse te donner des pistes. Là, on part vraiment de rien. - Alors on part de rien et je me dis, les ingrédients, après c'est des joker. Si
je galère de ouf. Je te dis : "Vas-y, donne moi un des ingrédients principaux ou secondaires".
Ou tu vois,
on devrait pouvoir le faire comme ça. Pour l'instant, je sais que c'est en deux mots.
Je sais que c'est un plat salé.
Parce que à priori c'est salé et quand je regarde ta tête à ce moment là...[rires] Moi, je gratte toutes les infos que je peux.
Et je sais que ça se cuisine vite parce que tu m'as dit que t'etais
un peu short time aujourd'hui.-Il sait qu'on est pressé.
- Le premier truc, c'est que pour l'instant, quand je t'ai parlé d'une recette salée, j'ai eu de l'étonnement.
Donc, j'ai un point de départ où je me dis : "ok c'est peut-être pas salé et
peut-être que tu m'as embrouillé la tête". Je vais essayer d'abord de trouver la lettre du premier mot. Comme ça, ça va me donner
un bon axe. Donc toi, t'as juste à penser la lettre du premier mot. Quand je la dirai, tu me diras stop dans ton esprit.
Est-ce que tu peux regarder l'écran en même temps parce que je sais que vous voulez essayer de le faire en même temps que moi
Tu penses juste à la première lettre et quand je la dis, tu dis stop dans ta tête.
Ca peut être A B C D E
F. OK, j'ai un relâchement ici. Ca veut dire que c'est passé.
C'est un début.Et ça, ça veut dire oui! OUI!
Je commence à avoir un petit peu de matière avant d'analyser Charles.
- J'essayais de.... Puisque comme je connais ses vidéos, je me dis tac tac tac. Faut que... [sifflements] (je l'embrouille).
- Eh oui, c'est ça.T'as pas lâché mais en fait, on lâche malgré soi. Ok, je
pense même savoir laquelle c'est. J'ai un petit doute sur celle qui suit mais je pense l'avoir là même.
-Est-ce que je te le dis ou pas, pour l'instant, pour voir... Je te le dis mais tu réagis pas forcément. Tu fais ce que
tu veux. Je pense que c'est un C.
-Je réagis pas forcément. - Mais tu devrais travailler dans les services secrets mon gars.
Soit une recette salée, soit une recette sucrée... -OUI!
Alors là, ce que vous venez de voir, ça s'appelle un pléonasme physique, c'est-à-dire, il y a un des deux sur lequel il a acquiescé.
Et c'était sur sucré.
Tu m'as fait un oui de la tête sur sucré. C'est terrible, non?
- Ouais et je m'en suis même pas rendu compte.- Donc, ça commence par un C
et c'est une recette sucrée! - 'Tain mais tu m'as fait acheter du poulet mon gars!
- Ouais c'était pour ma diète [rires]
- C'est énorme! - C'est trop facile sinon!
Parce que je lui ai envoyé une liste d'ingrédients mais y'a pas tout.- 'Tain c'est génial. Je dis bravo ok.
Y'a du poulet mon gars. Comment tu peux penser à une recette sucrée. 2 mots minimum
qui commence par un C, qui est une recette sucrée.Ok.
Maintenant, je vais faire des questions de déductions à laquelle tu dois me répondre sincèrement.
Est-ce que tu as déjà fait une recette de ce genre sur ta chaîne? - Oui.
la même recette?- Non. Est-ce que
l'un des ingrédients est un ingrédient que tu utilises souvent sur ta chaîne?- Oui. - Ok. D'accord.
C'est un ingrédient qu'on mange ? - Oui.
-C'est un ingrédient que tout le monde aime? [hésitations]
Je dirais 80% oui. - C'est familier comme ingrédient?
[Gestuelles] - Ouais, c'est le milieu quand même. - En fait, j'ose pas parler parce que si je te dis un truc, je vais me....(trahir)
-Mais moi, je fais ce que j'ai à faire.
Fais ce que tu as à faire.Je fais ce que j'ai à faire.
Quelquechose qui commence par un C et qui, d'après moi, contient du Nutella.
T'as les paumettes qui deviennent rouges et qui montent. En fait, tu sais la différence entre un vrai sourire et un faux sourire?
Le vrai sourire, on a les pommettes qui remontent et on plisse ici. Le fait que tu as un vrai sourire, ça me donne aussi des informations
sur je dis en fait.
-Ok, je vais essayer d'avoir la deuxième lettre. Pour ça, on va faire du kuberlimbisme.Tu vas me donner ton bras comme ça.
Et ce coup-ci, je regarde pas son visage. Tu penses à la deuxième lettre de ton premier mot.
Ca peut être A B C D E F G H I J K
L M N O P Q
R S T U V W X Y Z. Je l'ai pas, je vais le refaire. A B C D E F G H
I J K L...
Ok, je pense que c'est un H. Alors, je dis pas que c'est ça mais pour l'instant, je pense à de la chantilly.
De la chantilly au Nutella. Ca peut exister...Qu'est-ce qui existe d'autres comme ça...- Là, je pense
que peut-être, il ya des gens qui ont déjà des pistes - C'est vrai!
Tu penses que eux, ils peuvent trouver..
Vous, si vous avez trouvé avant moi. Dites le moi dans les commentaires, si vous avez trouvé avant moi. Je serai curieux de voir
statistiquement, combien de personnes l'ont déjà. Donc, ça veut dire que mes éléments sont bons, dans ces cas-là.
-Donc, ça veut dire que là, c'est n'est plus que de la déduction. En fait, la partie mentalisme
d'analyse, elle est faite. Et maintenant, ça veut dire qu'en déduction, on peut trouver. -'Tain, je suis trop une brêle! Charles de Gaulle! [rires]
Pour ceux qui ont regardé les vidéos, vous comprendrez.
Alors, j'en ai un qui pourrait marcher mais je me dis, en termes d'éléments de cuisine, tu m'as pas... Après t'as un gros sac.
T'as pu emmener des trucs. On utilise de l'huile qu'on fait frire. -Oui - Des churros
au Nutella. -Yes.
-C'est ca? - Yes! Eh franchement, tu es super fort. - Ben, c'est vrai que tu m'as pas fait un truc trop compliqué. Tu vois genre
les recettes de familles.
- Comme je disais avant, quand t'étais hors caméra, j'essayais de brouiller avec le poulet. Je me suis dit (que) je te donne quelques ingrédients
aussi
qui font vraiment que
je t'ai pas facilité la tâche.- Mais moi,
à 100%, j'étais sûr que c'était salé avant qu'on commence à parler ensemble quoi! C'est vraiment parce que j'ai vu dans ton regard et au
niveau du visage
une attente.Il n'y avait pas de logique et j'ai fait : "Ah putain il m'enfume!".
Le mec, il est bon. Le mec, il a essayé de m'enfumer. Maintenant, on va faire la recette ensemble.
Et ça, c'est sur ta chaîne.
-Ouais. -Donc, je mets le lien dans la description et puis directement, aussi à la fin de la vidéo, vous aurez juste à cliquer dans
dans la vignette qui va être là dans quelques secondes. - Ca va être super simple,
la recette qu'on va faire
Je vais te laisser un peu cuisiner. Nos abonnés vont voir ça sur ma chaîne.Rendez-vous tout de suite chez FastGood. Merci beaucoup.
Abonnez vous.Likez nous. Dites nous ce que vous en avez pensé. Ciao.